how does life come from randomness we
imagine the surface of the earth
billions of years ago was random molten
lava
but life is subtle and complex and
requires a lot of structure how could it
be that structure could form from
randomness if the system you're looking
at is isolated eventually that system
will randomize up to the extent that
there is no interesting structure it
will maximize entropy or disorder so you
wouldn't expect to see anything that's
because if any structure tried to form
the random motion of the molecules would
knock apart whatever starts however if
you have some other source of energy
that keeps the system out of equilibrium
again the surface of the earth but now
the Sun is beating down on it that extra
source of energy could smash things
together and create structures
structures that are solid enough that
the little random motions of the
background pieces never disrupt it or at
least don't have enough time to and the
structures could grow and grow that's a
nice little cartoon story but is it true
well recently there have been
breakthroughs in understanding what's
called non equilibrium processes
and proposals to explain how structure
can come from these seemingly random
systems those structures could be
anything but of course one of the most
exciting would be could it be life RNA
molecules and everything that comes
after that they're delicate little
beings and you might worry that put in a
little soup the random motion would
destroy them but perhaps they're not so
delicate and perhaps they're even a
predictive consequence of a random earth
but with energy imposed into the system
that is something we can't answer now
but is an exciting new vein or way of
people are thinking about the problem
and hope to solve it